[Musique]
bertrand caruge bonjour bonjour à toutes
et à tous bonjour yves notre invité
gilbert couturier bonjour bonjour
monsieur kaouche point g aux auditeurs
de la première libère couturier mère du
gros morne mais c'est davantage le
troisième vice-président de cap nord la
communauté d'agglomération du pays nord
de la martinique que nous accueillons ce
matin le troisième vice-président de cap
nord et membre de la commission
développement rural et agricole et vous
êtes venu nous parler d'un programme
d'un programme européen en lien avec les
fonds européens
il y aura un séminaire de travail après
demain jeudi au morne-rouge autour de ce
programme leader
donc en lien que les fonds européens je
le disais est doté d'un peu plus d'un
million neuf cent mille euros c'est pas
mal alors bousseton le nord avec leader
c'est ça vous pensez qu'avec ce
programme vous pouvez booster le
territoire nord alors je crois qu'il est
important de pouvoir aurait
effectivement rappelé que ce dispositif
appelé dispositif vie dure les deux qui
signifie liaison entre les actions le
développement économique rural et bien
devant décider que après l'opération
leader les dispositifs vidéo de 2007
2013 où c'est plus de 46 dossiers
opération qui a été qu'ils ont été
financier à hauteur de 1 million neuf
cent quarante et un mille ou et bien
pour le dispositif vidéo de 2014 2020
bien véritablement thème est porteur de
projet de pouvoir
vraiment s'inscrire à porter les projets
les accompagner puisque n'oublions pas
que le nom est en majorité un territoire
rural
ben oui voilà c'est ce que j'allais dire
bon ben on va venir à cette journée de
jeudi
comment vous allez donc opérer la
présentation de ce programme et à qui ça
s'adresse mais c'est un programme
européen leader qui vise à soutenir
essentiellement ou peut être avant tout
des projets pilotes en zone rurale mais
mais pas que pas exclusivement
c'est vrai que en mettant en place et
puis en faisant le choix que de mettre
en avant l'agriculture puisque d'autres
jeux d'hiver pci ont pris d'autres
secteurs y en a qui y ont pris le tout
il y en a qui ont pris la mer nous nous
avons choisi l'agriculture puisque ce
que nous représentons
et puis il faut rappeler que sur les 18
communes de cap nau et c'est ça la
priorité du président mathieu est bien
dans ses dix huit communes
il y à une désertification et notamment
des quartiers donc des boues qui sont de
plus en plus moribond et donc les
bourses ont aussi concerné les boues
sont concernés mais nous avons aussi des
quartiers où avant nous avions des
comédies comme un seul hier des petites
boutiques des activités qui se faisait
et qui de plus en plus sont en train de
mettre la clé sous préparation il est
important que nous puissions nous dire
il faut accompagner si ces commerces
existants mais aussi accompagner des
porteurs de projets et qui veulent
rester dans les quartiers accompagner
les commerces du bout en fait ce qui
existe le accompagner leur permettre de
s'inscrire dans cette dynamique
c'est pour ça que le
dans le dispositif rideau que nous avons
en mettant en place d'abord défini cinq
axes et parmi ces actes là il y a
le premier axe et en connaître tous les
agricultures du nom de pour mieux de la
compagnie connaître leurs besoins
le jazz est là je vous interromps
gilbert couturier parce que donc ça veut
dire que cape noire est prêt à financer
une sorte quoi d'études c'est ça pour
mieux connaître tous les agriculteurs du
nord mais on va vous devriez déjà
connaître les les agriculteurs enfin
vous en particulier mais quand vous
connaissez vous mort nommé au fait vous
dit reconnaître les agricultures du nord
ces dix-huit communes et nous avons des
agriculteurs qui sont dans des
situations je prends l'exemple
s'il faut donner l'exemple puisque vous
faites au népal a parlé d'une commune
allait parler pour les deux territoires
de 18 communes
cent dix mille habitants on va foncer
demi ou le spécialiste des ignames
d'antan désigne m qui est ensuite il
distille gosse est bien pour accéder sur
sa en exploitation et bien c'est à 2 à 2
dan s'il reste quelques jeunes de sur ce
point il faut faciliter l'accès est
facilité d'accès on ne peut pas toujours
dire qu'on fait le chemin comme ça donc
il faudra qu'elle techniques apportées
pour cette agriculture qui fait un
travail extraordinaire qui je veux dire
l'un des derniers mohicans des la
tradition de la production alors désigne
âme d'antan il vient paulinia me
portugaise et bien à ces personnes là il
faut les accompagner
et c'est pour cela que cap nord en
mettant en place le dispositif leader eh
bien on peut trouver des fonds pouvant
permettre l'accompagnement de ces
personnes là pouvoir faciliter le au
train train parce que vous faites une
culture qui n'a pas les moyens bien il
ne pourra jamais vivre de son métier
d'accord alors donc pas voilà c'est vous
vous intervenez quand même sur cette
première action puisque il s'agit vous
disiez de finance et de la réalisation
de recensement de base de données de
plan d'action pour connaître les
agriculteurs du nord donc c'est un
exemple un autre exemple de de ces fonds
européens
afin quoi pourrait servir ces fonds
européens dans le cadre de ce programme
leader pour la zone rurale qui comme est
considérée cap nord c'est la
valorisation de produits innovants des
initiatives innovantes ça par contre
c'est un aspect qu'il faut souligner
donc voilà il ya un aspect de modernisme
modernité de prospective quoi sur eux
effectivement jean compte que de plus en
plus les porteurs de projets et pour le
nord il y à des créations il ya de
nouveaux projets d originalité qui
arrive
et sur ce point là il faut accompagner
les porteurs de projets je veux quand
même dire que tout le monde il faut
savoir quel type de projet que tu
d'action qui peut entrer dans les dents
ces dispositifs et qui peut bénéficier
donc je rappelle que si il y à des
établissements publics comme cap nau
enfin les autres pc de la martinique
il y a aussi des collectivités
territoriales qui puissent en bénéficier
il ya la chambre des chambres
consulaires peuvent bénéficier puisque
vous faites il ya des transformations
elissalde des cessions d'actifs
ensuite il y a aussi les inter
e les interprofessions qui peuvent se
mettre en place
il y a les groupements d'agriculteurs et
c'est pour ça qu'en faisant ce travail
d'ensemble
donc nous sommes dits nous nous disons
que c'est eux millions 9 on a quand même
des délais parce qu'en fait il y à déjà
peau cap nord il y a cinq dossiers déjà
étudier et préparer donc qui sont déjà
là en attente et nous nous croyons
vérité mais il ya encore des fonds à
allouer parce que si vous faites cette
journée de jeudi pour présenter ce
programme pour sensibiliser des porteurs
de projets sont en cours pour les
audiences que le nom dans le nom il ya
des choses qui puisqu'ils sont faisable
il ya des choses qui se dit seul qui se
déroule invité la martinique à venir
voir ce territoire que souvent
abandonnés on pense que vous faites
c'est un territoire disais alors que
toute la richesse de la martinique
je prends quand nous mais il faut tenir
et c'est bien sûr la loi est si bien sûr
il ya les hardes aux commandes que nous
fournissons le sud nous fournissons la
martinique dont je crois qu'au fait le
nom il ya des choses extraordinaires qui
se passe et nous évitons au mont rouge
ce jeudi de 8 heures à 15 heures ce
jeudi 27 alors 2 qui dit aux gens qui
doivent venir et qui précisément vous
invitez qui à qui vous voulez vous
adresser prioritairement de demander les
porteurs de projet est ce qui reste ce
qu'il est ce qu'il reste élevé l'autre
qui de 1 million 9 qui est là qui est
déjà entamée mais non elle voudrait
faire une confusion avec que l'enveloppé
de 1 million neuf cent quarante et un
mille cauneille dans le dispositif
leader 2007 2013
là c'est notre dispositif 2014-2020 où
il y à un million neuf mais voilà il
faut rentrer là dedans et c'est deux
millions 9
on ne fait que commencer à entamer le
dossier et c'est à partir de cela au
l'ensemble des factures de tête aux eaux
monter d'ici
avant 2022 et puisqu'on a constaté sur
l'ensemble de la france
il y avait un set de retard que les
dispositifs rompuy qui n'est pas faute à
capitol hill photo l'idéal ide en
martinique
mais c'est plus une difficulté qu'on a
rencontrés dans l'ensemble des
dispositifs leader sur la france ainsi
que même le principe est toujours le
même pour ceux qui seraient intéressés à
entrer dans ce programme leader à être
financés comme ça par ces fonds
européens
il faut quand même c'est un
remboursement d'une partie d'un
investissement sur le projet oui c'est
mais on est d'accord mais sur ce qui est
dit bruce ton façon je prends l'exemple
de quelqu'un qui a une idée bien que
vous m l'idée votre savoir ce que ce
projet de voir le jour
cette personne est accompagné ce porteur
de projet d'accompagner de 25000 euros
donc il y un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui existent et c'est de
dire que vous faites mais ce qui est
important c'est de dire à tous ces
porteurs de projets d'être là au monde
riche jeudi puisque nous aurons
plusieurs intervenantes donc on
déjà les autres et puis s'ils se sont
associés pour venir apporter mais on a
on a des cabinets conseils qui seront
présents on a les techniciens qui sont
là ce qui est important c'est de montrer
le travail qui se fait et quand je
prends un exemple de de l'opération 2007
2012 2013
et parmi les opérations originales on à
la reprise de du musée de la banane et
le maire asie où nestor azérot qui fait
aussi partie de cap nau guide qui a
contribué qui a fait avec le président
mathieu et bien tout chaque je crois que
c'est apporter la touche démontré que
dans le nom on peut continuer à faire
comme d'autres endroits martinique a
animé à développer l'économie a
développé les changes a gardé aussi les
populations puisque nous savons que les
populations
par ailleurs pour s'installer parce que
vous faites parce que tout se passera
dans le centre dans le sud est sea
constat que vous faites le travail
autour du dispositif bouton
booth ont le nom il ya via le dispositif
reader oui alors vous allez il y aura
des témoignages aussi un sessad et
procurer tous ceux qui ont bénéficié le
dispositif 2007-2014 2013 au temps pour
moi et bien ils seront là pour venir
témoigner dit ou fait comment et combien
ils ont pu apporter quelles sont les
difficultés qu'ils ont rencontrées
aujourd'hui à quel niveau se trouve le
opération et puis les nouveaux porteurs
de projets qui sont là et bien qu'ils
pourront y participer est présenté aussi
le comité de programmation qui est là
puisque vous faites il faut expliquer
aux fêtes le fonctionnement de leader
donc quand on a des dossiers à traiter
en comité de programmation
eh bien on a un collège de collèges
publics conclure on a un collège privé
donc avec des commerçants avec des
artisans avec eux tous ceux qui
contribuent c'est de diouf est ce ce
dispositif et cette opération qui est
mise en place pour permettre aux gens de
savoir
il existe des dispositifs ex des moyens
et de pouvoirs entre participer voilà
booster le nord avec leader voilà donc
séminaire de travail jeudi au
morne-rouge au millenium c'est avoue
yves bonne journée